joining us on the program today is bill
share
who many in the audience love to hate
and
some hate to love i think we would say
um contributor to the washington monthly
political magazine
real clear politics and also host of the
history podcast
when america worked bill always good to
have you
great to talk to you as well so let's
start maybe with
something that will shock the audience
if you had to say
what's your biggest criticism of biden
so far
where do you stand well i would say and
look i've been very annoying about this
from the get-go
um i think biden needs to find a way to
get the 60 on things or at least try
to get the 60 on things uh you can't do
everything through budget reconciliation
you're not going to abolish the
filibuster with mansion cinema's
opposition
even if you reform the filibuster that's
not eliminating the filibuster it
doesn't mean that
uh everything's going to glide right
through if that guy changed
so on things like you know voting rights
immigration minimum wage uh
you need to find a path to 60 or it's
not going to happen
uh and so i think you need that
breakthrough you need that
there's so much mistrust you need a
breakthrough moment to create that
working relationship
i think the relief bill was the best
chance to get that
and i can't begrudge biden for
thinking hey i got 50 votes in hand i
can get 1.9 trillion
i can make a massive dent in child
poverty
i'm going to act when i can act i mean
that's not an unreasonable calculation
to have made
but i do worry that if
it's a missed opportunity to get the 60
on something
is he going to be able to get the 60 on
anything right
well so uncovered relief i mean listen
it's like if you step back
there's a story to tell that's very uh
compelling right now which is
he promised 2000 and to us that sounded
like 2
000 more but then it became adding 1400
to the 6th
to the 6th and he said right away but it
took two months and he said 15
minimum wage and then that's gone and
then you kind of
you break it down and it's okay right
away
i mean how quickly can this actually be
done so so maybe
expectation should have been different 2
000 total versus 2 000 more
yeah i don't know i i was i was thinking
he meant 2 000 more as well
counting 600 from six months prior is a
little bit of a question mark to me
minimum wage listen the parliamentarian
thing
it it you know you could overrule the
parliamentarian but then you almost
certainly lose at least one democratic
senator
if you force it into the bill so it
really wasn't going to pass and then i'm
kind of like i guess this is okay i
don't know
well look just taking the bill in of
itself forget my own forget forget my
screamishes about what comes next
yep it's a very popular bill right the
criticism of 1400
versus 2 000 that's not resonating in
the country
the the checks were the most popular
aspect of the bill and all the polling
that i saw
that's important which is 2 000 more
or 2000 total is huge in the political
space
but when you pull people they're happy
about the 1400 period
they have the 1400 i i think they are
going to be happy
at least the parents are going to be
happy about the expanded
child tax credit yeah when those monthly
checks uh come in
uh and uh to get a win off the bed is is
is no small thing you want to show
you're acting
he was able to act within 50 days that
is a good shot in the arm
uh for any uh initial president so
i i don't think any in the short term
it's all good the question now is
can he find a way to get something else
that would show hey i can find 10
republicans who can move us on these
other
fronts because because the the risk is i
mean look right in right now you
mentioned the minimum wage thing yeah
there's two things about the minimum
wage 15 million wages that are of note
one is that you do not have 50
democratic centers for 15.
right they do not exist you lost eight
vote eight senators on that on the
democratic side on that vote so
it goes beyond the parliamentary
um the rules questions there right uh
so some people say well biden betrayed
his promise he didn't betray his promise
you never had 50 democrats who promised
that
in the first place undeniable so you
need to work on those eight
or you need to accept less than 15
and get the 60 some way somehow
but at the same time biden showed
he is very reluctant to bend those rules
and break those norms and
i think he is at least in the near term
stuck between these two positions
stuck between i'm going to get done what
we need to get done
and i'm not going to let the republicans
veto my agenda
but i'm not going to push hard to change
the rules right those two positions
don't mesh
something's got to give because if
you put a minimum wage bill on the floor
you put a voting rights bill on the
floor
you put an immigration bill on the floor
and they all get filibustered and you
don't move
one way or the other then you get i
think you get much
bigger frustration beer confusion yeah i
don't get what you're doing guy
pick a lane yeah yeah and for people who
are watching and they thought bill just
pulled out a second microphone that was
actually
his cat's tail um so bloomberg reported
yesterday the next big focus is going to
be
tax reform everything that is being
reported as
being in the bill are things biden ran
on so there's there's no shock there in
terms of what
would be in the bill the white house
restating
taxes wouldn't go up for anyone earning
under four hundred thousand dollars a
year
that seems to be mostly true although
depending on what's
in changes for path passed through
business entities
that may or may not actually be the case
but we we have to wait and see
what i said earlier in looking at the
details of this
is that i think you're going to get
total republican opposition to doing
anything that could be
labeled a tax increase given the
pandemic situation
and probably even some democrats on
everything other than raising the
corporate tax rate so
while a lot of it is exactly what biden
promised
and what the uh many economists say
would be um a deficit negative revenue
positive however you want to do it i
think
that politically the next year would be
very tough for most of what's in that
a proposal well this is the tough thing
when when you
say republicans are beyond the pale
there's no way you can get 10 on
anything it's a fool's game it's lucy in
the football
don't embarrass yourself by trying yup
get what you can get done
with 50. that only works if you have
50. right uh so taxes
and spending you can do through
reconciliation those are budgetary
matters
so the thing that's big up on a buyer's
agenda coming up is infrastructure
you can do infrastructure by and large
to reconciliation
and there's probably a tax component to
that
but if you don't have unanimity among
your 50 democrats
not only can you not get it done it is
much more politically embarrassing to
not get it done
cause all the fault is on you you said
you were gonna do these things with your
party and you can't get your party in
line
that's very politically dangerous uh so
if you don't have that expectation that
you need 60 on these things if you if if
the assumption was
uh in the populace oh yeah you need 60
on these things we need to have
bipartisan support
over republicans the one holding this up
i'm going to punish those guys
in november if the expedition is 50 and
then you don't get it done then you take
all the blame uh and we know that
mansion we know that angus king
we know that some other democrats are
squeamish about more
spending without offsets without revenue
whether that's tax increase or spending
cuts
and what those tax increases and
spending cuts should be
that's where things get very dicey to
talk a little bit about the republican
party
um one of the most frequent you know i
get
ten forms of these questions every week
is the republican party still the party
of trump
is the 2024 nomination trumps if he
wants it what happens in 2022 with
people that are really only known for
being trumpists like marjorie taylor
green lauren bober and madison cawthorn
etc
to me it seems that these things are all
sort of interrelated trumpet is cpac
speech
not announcing 24 but saying donate to
me
and i'll be the king maker and we're
going to get the rhinos out
is is 2022 and
maybe adjudicating these trumpian
members of congress in 2022
is that a signal about the future of the
party
well yeah i i would assume so i mean it
seems like trump
is is still in the game yeah we can we
can
speculate whether he went to 2024 or not
but he he's not taking a breather he's
not just playing golf he
he is getting involved in primary
battles encouraging primary battles
putting his thumb on the scale uh you
know we'll have to see
how many people get nominated or get
ousted in republican primaries
uh because of trump's involvement
uh and then we'll see in the general
election
if being trumpy helps or hurts
in a general election we we have had
examples in the past
where republicans went too far off the
deep end
and lost winnable seats uh
there's a great expectation that 2022
will be a good republican year i mean
right terms
go well for the president's party uh
there's a number of tenuous
house seats that are up uh and i mean
republicans have to do some defending on
the senate side
uh but uh and there's also the
the auditioning question will
republicans draw lines for the house
races that will
advantage them in 2022 that's that's all
a little unclear at this point
but there's a certain expectation that
this will be a good republican year
if trump blows it for them if there were
things that they could have won
and trump's involvement hurts them that
does not
that that might bring out the voices in
the republican party
saying hey this should not be trump's
party he has heard it he hurt us in
georgia
in 2020 and he's still hurting us now or
there may be folks that say
who cares who cares if we win or lose
this is trump's party
you know live or die and we're we're
gonna fight the fight and fight the
liberals in the secular media and the
socialists
and who wins the elections is secondary
to us
uh we don't know you know how much trump
has
mutated the dna of the gop
where they become immune to caring about
electoral considerations
right i mean you see polling like 64
percent of republicans would follow
trump to a new party
80-something percent want trump to
remain involved in politics in some way
it seems as though the electorate is
far more positive on trump than the
elected officials are
privately from what the reports are but
it seems the elected officials are still
being careful
because they don't seem to know what the
power of trump will be in the next
election cycle or two
yeah they're afraid they're afraid for
their own seats and
most republicans who are in office now
can only lose their seats through a
primary not through a general
there's not a lot of crossover uh
split ticket purple state purple
district republicans at this point
uh now having said that and i have a
theory
that's not based on a ton of history
because there's only so many examples of
this
but i think you got to lose the
presidency
three times in a row before party can
conclude
hey it's not you it's me you know
democrats
lost with carter lost with mondale lost
with dukakis
then you get bill clinton then you get a
guy running on welfare reform a guy who
will
execute a prisoner with a 70 iq
uh a guy who will assist a soldier jesse
jackson to his face
and say and have the base voters say
well what are you gonna do
and you gotta you gotta attack the
middle we tried it the liberal way it
didn't work
you gotta really lose a lot right or
your base voters to say i'm really sick
and tired of losing
and your average trump die hard is not
sick
of donald trump they have not lost
enough
to care now and maybe that might my
rule of three doesn't work with trump
voters maybe they'll never care because
they're so uh
wedded to him but i think having the one
loss
clearly is not sufficient to break that
bond yeah well
there's no doubt about that and
especially when you know that a lot of
the trump people
were not really involved in politics
anyway so a lot of those
sort of norms may not apply and many
republicans might rationalize
yeah we lost one but trump wasn't even
really like the rest of us anyway he was
sort of this other thing so so there may
be a lot of there
on both in the trumpian wing and the
non-trumpian wing there may be
rationalizations for why they won't care
well you know lindsey graham said it
pretty openly to axios that
you know trump has a good side and a
dark side but clearly he brings
out a certain group of voters that
republicans need and so we got to stick
with that but you know in his heart
lindsey graham's not a trump
not trumper but you but he's sucky up to
him as he thinks that's what the party
uh needs to do now to go back to my
other point about biden
and get into 60 i don't think this is a
unanimous
feeling amongst all republicans
especially senate republicans we know
there's a class
of senate republicans that does not care
for trump whether they are
the mitt romneys and lisa murkowskis and
the susan collins or the folks who are
saying sia
like rob portman and richard burr uh and
roy blunt
they don't they don't want the party to
be a trumpian party now
we don't know how far they will go
to cause a rift we know that
it's not something that can happen
magically organically because they
stayed in lockstep against the rescue
plan against the pandemic relief bill
right
if you were to exploit those divisions
you need to work
at it and uh now some people might think
you're naive bill there's you can't work
hard enough there's no way to break
that bond and look that may be the case
i can't
mind read these republicans yeah but i
do think there
there is evidence of differentiation
between those senators
that i would like to see tried to see
could could you exploit that
call why didn't that rift make the case
to the romneys and the portman saying
look it's not just good for me
it's good for you it's good for your
party
you don't want your party to be a
trumpian party you don't want your
prayer to be
a nihilistic party show that we you can
work with us
and it'll be good for your party long
term uh
again i can't believe it's going to work
but i would certainly try it
and i think it will make biden look good
in the trying
uh to occupy a space where he's putting
plans on the floor that are popular with
the public
and if they get blocked by republicans
republicans pay the price
yeah that's that's treasury i would like
to see more of yeah i i think that the
it would unquestionably make joe biden
look good and and that may be why there
will be desperation to avoid
the breaking of the ranks from from the
republican party but we will see which
uh
which forces is stronger in the end i
mean quite quite frankly that's what
it'll come down to
bill share contributor to the washington
monthly
to politico magazine to real clear
politics and also host of the
history podcast when america worked bill
it's always great to have you on
you too talk to you soon